je vous avoue que j'ai regardé en fond
sonore parce que l'on préparait le repas
en famille poterie terre donc j'ai pas
vraiment créateurs pensent qu'à ce
qu'ils disaient si ce n'est que je me
posais la question de talent s il y
avait un nouveau confinant au paraguay
bon c'est toujours la même bien le même
discours à ses on en a ras-le-bol ans
c'est répétitif un petit peu il ferme
les les théâtres les restaurants surtout
c'est quand même inadmissible des choses
comme ça on sait même pas quand ils vont
les rouvrir parce que il dit rien ils
cachent tous qu'il est la vaccination ne
va pas assez vite
il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont pas il
s'en fout de nous
il y va il va partout ils empêchent les
gens de d'aller au théâtre d'aller au
cinéma d'aller en gym d'aller de faire
les achats parce que on dans l'est
une ferme à teaser sur moment où les
boulangers ils ont besoin de bosser ces
îles ont ils ont pas beaucoup bossé je
trouve que c'est inadmissible on leur
retire le pain de la bouche comme on dit
mais pas grand chose mais ce que je veux
c'est vrai que j'étais un peu déconnecté
de la politique cette année
pourquoi tant d'intérêt de manque de
confiance qui se raconte aussi est ce
que vous attendez quelque chose en
particulier des manuels main trop
[Applaudissements]
plus encouragements et de compassion
plus de compréhension de ce que vraiment
on ressent nous dans la vraie vie
maintenant j'ai pas du tout suivi et on
était sûrs du nouvel an du conte été
longue et des patients soit c'est tout
ce qui se passe en ce moment on a juste
envie que ça change
et du coup à chaque fois j'attends une
bonne nouvelle non du coup on n'a pas
regardé en havre on va penser on a fait
le jour de l'an à deux et puis ça ne
nous a même pas traversé l'esprit
en général je m'intéresse quand même à
la politique mais
vous que peut-être en ce moment
je suis un peu sorti ou
on s'est un peu mis sur nous
à célébrer
vraiment oublié
j'ai un peu perdu espoir dans cette
présidence donc j'attends pas vraiment
grand chose en ce moment malheureusement
il ya aussi des circonstances
atténuantes mais c'est un peu période
spéciale mais j'attends pas vraiment
grand chose
peut-être qu'ils se réveillent un petit
peu
leadership de
peu de changements écoutez j'ai écouté
ça vite fait j'ai trouvé ça un peu froid
vu les circonstances actuelles
j'ai trouvé qu'il n'était pas très
chaleureux vis-à-vis de la population
française et de son gouvernement
vu les circonstances actuelles je trouve
que le gouvernement ne fait pas beaucoup
d'efforts pour remettre en place
malheureusement la culture qui est
catastrophique
les cinémas le teatro et tout ça et où
les brasseries qu'ils ont besoin
deux clients et je trouve que pour les
fêtes le gouvernement aurait dû faire un
effort pour réouvrir ses bras ses
restaurants pour tous ces gens là
puissent travailler et il ya plein de
personnes seules
ce jour là qui sera vu peut-être aller
au restaurant
malheureusement ils sont restés chez
vous et je trouve que la situation en
france
économique est très grave je sais bien
qu'ils aient le virus mais bon si ce
virus il ya longtemps alors on va faire
faillite
[Musique]